hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast harnessing the power of
healthcare data with causal machine
learning to drive personalized and
effective treatment interventions
presented by dr. aya coolio I am Brenda
Kelly chem lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's presentation
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking site the
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning we'd also like to acknowledge
the sea and en media group for help with
programming and promotion of this event
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green QA
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
or answer as many of your questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation please also notice that
you'll be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have trouble
hearing or seeing the presentation
properly please click on a support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the c/e button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
for obtaining your credits I'd now like
to introduce today's presenter dr. irq
Liam I Opilio the co-founder and
executive vice president of gns has
promoted the use of the company's
technology in the biopharma industry one
of the inventors companies computational
platform for work has helped major
players such as biogen idec and Johnson
& Johnson to make computer-driven
discoveries for the respective R&D
programs if you would like more
information about our speaker please
click on their photo image in the top
right please join me in welcoming dr.
aya Khalil
I'll now turn it over to her for her
presentation oh and thank you for the
invitation to present today it is my
pleasure so I'd love to thank you
organizers for the traffic movie and I
brother had said my talk today focuses
on the use and how we leverage machine
learning toggle machine really bribe
personalized license so big data has
become now a big buzzword in our
industry especially for those of us
who've been in this for a while I think
there was a time when we used to call
Big Data by another name it was called
systems biology and what it was really
about was enabling biologists folks in
the medical field of healthcare field to
build beyond just being able to observe
one time about looking at many many
different variables and factors so being
able to keep went to whole genome
observe transcriptional levels at scale
at the genomic micrornas proteomics
metabolomics and link this all the way
to the filmic our ability to observe how
the granular genetics micro RNA can
actually impact things on the phenotypic
and physiological level and fifteen
years ago these technologies were just
starting to emerge now they're becoming
more ubiquitous and are shedding light
in their systems whether it's biological
medical or health care in ways that we
couldn't even imagine so but with all
this data comes a challenge and the
challenge is how do we actually make
sense of this so we can go into random
news at any given day and learn about
how you know our propensity for drinking
coffee and then potentially lead to a
mayra to disorders which may or may not
cause various effects so we're faced
with all of the data the data can be
seen as a set of patterns or
correlations but really our goal is to
go beyond the patterns of formation and
learn what causes like in the season and
by getting at underlying causality where
we can get to insights that we couldn't
two before with the data that we have
access people so we're faced with this
perfect opportunity of an exponential
rise in data and really our ability to
collect it at scale at pops now that are
positive massive number of increased and
intervention and breakthroughs in
machine learning and cloud computing and
our goal or my goal has been really
developing algorithms that can go beyond
what we already know what's already
established in the literature and
algorithms that answer what I like to
call the what kick you can get at causal
mechanisms than we could start to ask
and not only predict outcomes for
patients but what is the lightning and
for those of you who are on the line
that would like to get some of these
slides and materials please feel free to
email me at the end of this presentation
and I would be happy I services so one
way to look at machine learning and
predictive modeling this is a tournament
that was up reported by Davenport and
one of his mom Davenport in one of the
publications and books you know we can
think of taking data and I'm doing just
standard report to typical analyses that
measure or try to predict okay what's up
what's coming with down forecasting and
even predictive modeling that looks at
what will happen next our goal is to go
beyond predictive modeling and to learn
from the data and optimize around the
data learn directly from the data and
infer new mechanism new effects beyond
what's directly in the data itself
answering the question of what will
happen if I do this so the underlying
mathematics that we chose to explore and
leverage is what we call the mathematics
of causality so we can look at a data
set and start to look at what are the
patterns of correlations and we can ask
those a pearl it would be be four lay
today and we can even try to attach arab
to those correlations and ask you is
there a direction to it causal
association and it turns out that
mathematically with just two variables
a pimp or late would be and you can even
ask for the closet and you can be 44 @
Association but you can't distinguish
between these two graphs or associations
need to wrap them all when we can
introduce an exhaustive variable a third
variable and in biology and measurement
medicine that variable can be a genetic
factor it could also be a drug or an
environmental factor that's where
mathematically you can probabilistic we
start to discern 10 a caused B or
because a and C in this case can have
event in your system in your data any
intervention that's driving variation in
your data and your outputs be it on a
molecular level or cleaner tific or
physiological level and mathematically
these two probabilities probability of
these models given now any data set that
you might be comparing it to are
different and move for differently given
this exact variable and so we can start
to sort out soon it's a what is what's
driving he in my system in my data that
I enter study urge at be driving a there
are also ways to discern and try to come
up with patterns of probabilistic
causality when you don't know what the
observables are especially in the
context of observational data and one
can then particle model and look at
graphical structures that would test
there's a drive teeth or be directv and
if a and B are weakly associated each
other the more and more that we start to
learn and pick up these kinds of grass
we can start to serve out even within
the context of observational variable
data from patterns of correlation causal
association the best the underlying
mathematics and our goal was to take
that map now and leverage it exhale so
we want to be able to do it for any kind
of variable any kind of data set because
when we talk about predicting outcomes
it's going to be a combination of
measures and variables that allow you to
model what's happening in the suspense
weren't directly from data the
relationships between these variables
and want to do it at scale so what we
set out to do was really take that
mathematics
underlying mathematics that I had just
described that it can recognize the
foreign words and developed by folks
like to be a parent established the
mathematics of causality we've included
that now in two sets of algorithms that
can take in raw data and eliminate kinds
of data that you can learn the
interaction directly from your data set
the data that you're feeding into the
algorithm want to be able to do it
quickly and what we end up learning here
is not just a single model a
probabilistic directed graphical models
underlying the data but we've learnt
ensemble controls there could be more
than one model that could actually
represent your data and in learning
these ensembles that's one way to guard
against overfitting as well capturing
the uncertainty underlying the data and
once we have it available when I run
simulations to make very specific
predictions predictions down to the
individual person by person number by
number so in a little bit more depth so
what I described is the process now of
taking in data that might be diverse and
might be massive multimodal of different
client assistant pipes we are now going
to run this through an engine the first
page of that engine is what we call the
reverse engineering for learning of the
probabilistic causal association is
underlying if your data set and the
first thing you need to do the little
sorority model you're going to use a
probabilistic baby and frameworks of
scoring involve the motivation behind
that is to be able to sort out these
directed a ballistic age difference
paagal graphs but also the Bayesian
framework is one way to guard against
written because you're always fitting to
the elite most complicated model but
it's most likely the messes enter data
and then we go through a process of
optimization we're going to now
parameter eyes and feed the model and
different kinds of networks and we're
going to involve them as a function of
temperature and we're going to keep
evolving done until we end up with the
optimal set of models ensemble models
which represents a sampling of the
possible
models that could fit your data and in
that sampling once we have that now we
can run simulations and ask very
specific and targeted questions what
would happen if i were to condition this
model on a phenotype that matches a
specification and i were to modulate a
therapeutic target or pathway with an
outpatient down-regulate how would that
impact you and the answers will come out
of which the usually or distributions
reflect uncertainty in the models that
are generated and that became like half
1170 and we know what I use that
uncertainty to say hmmm Duke's
distribution when I upregulates that
target that drug that pathway is very
different than that one and I can say
with some confidence how likely that is
to impact an outcome measure and a
specificity so that's the prophet end to
end um and what I want to do next is
really go through now where you're
applying this how we refinement and what
this plaque on around the words
engineering probabilistic networks and
publish the probable mechanisms
underlying their data and then running
simulations ask what is custom where
have they gotten traction and how we can
able to use them to hopefully advance
our understanding of mechanisms driving
disease as well as our ability to
predict some populations and biomarkers
of response and maybe eventually apply
this in a planet circling and so one of
the things that has emerged as i
described earlier with our ability to
measure more and more and now we can
actually join us large-scale study that
combine the measurement of genetic
molecular levels different flavors of
molecular variables with medical
phenotypes producing large sets of coke
over hundreds and possibly thousands of
faces and we're working with and
collaborating with various entities from
foundations like secure hundred disease
initiative foundation most myeloma
Research Foundation to the innova
hospital system and global economics to
really leverage the data
and identify what we can learn from them
and more and more increasingly with the
advent that looks like medical records
you can also apply these algorithms to
EMR data set so this is an example of
work that we conducted leveraging the
refs platform with reverse engineering
and for accumulation learn models that
predict the transition from normal
diabetes the pre diabetes people
diabetes those who are interested in
delving into the penny more deeply I
just work has been published at the
journal by DT science and technology and
you can access it there but I will spend
too much time on it there's like to
spend a bit more time on the data set of
studies that measured the heats anomic
and genomic studies but are the point
being that now sort of with the ability
to collect different kinds of data that
I'll match two different questions and
problems from real-world datasets to
omit two combinations are up and you can
combine that now with this capability to
reverse engineer these models to
represent a that and then run your own
simulations it's really cool and
different applications of solutions that
spans the discovery of new biology
biomarker discovery and even Apple
futures in the real world around
comparative effectiveness so now I will
go into a bit more depth I learned a
couple of ETA study and the time that we
have 12 chart where the work this
building's Norfolk's which is a recent
study we aim to a ten-point in the
coming month publish these results but I
thought it peaceful to see how we
thought about really leveraging this
large scale data sets to get at toggle
mechanisms underlying cardiometabolic
disease and cardiovascular disease and
so it always does start with the data
and in this study this was designed to
generate large data sets that we in
combined venerate comprehensive disease
models to come up with such a low target
biomarkers as well as a fine a patient
diagnostic
the setting for back to motivation and
so to do that the study focus is on 7500
patients and different trials are being
robbed within that 7500 starting with a
pilot study where the data set is
divided into a discovery and validation
from work and then the cohort is
expanded and again we set this up as a
discovery and validation for and the
forward is expanded again to do
additional discovery and then final
validation and the key here is that in
this designs are cognizant of the media
table have a phase of training these
models and validating them expanding the
cohorts and adding in more data on
location and validating those and then
finally having our finally discovered
second validation and that's built into
the design of the study from the get-go
and then on each of these patients we
are measuring cardiac CT and imaging
analysis a lot of this work started with
methods around the phenotyping and
getting quantitative she mixes with
measurements and then whole genome DNA
sequences on are measured along with RNA
transcriptomic and sequence data as well
as proteomics and metabolomics so if i
multiply element study where DNA
variation of people think is sort of
seen as the answer by which we're going
to start to tease out these causal
mechanisms and connect them to the end
point to the phenotypes that was
measured insist
you
so that's like two and we're now in the
pilot phase of learning and validation
eight data modalities measured in
education we took some bait data
modalities and ran through an exercise
of normalizing data checking the quality
control and filtering for the variables
that actually shows signal data so that
led to us now focusing our modeling
effort and the data frame that we
entered into the reverse engineering
product innovation on 103,000 fire and
65 variables we ran those variables
across then those hundreds of patients
and reverse engineered models the end
point of that reverse engineering
exercise was a model where we have to
explore over 10 to the 18th network
fragment that exploration was enabled by
running deal where the bomb cloud and
paralyzing them and we ended up sampling
6 times 10 to the 11th network to come
up with our final ensemble and then once
you have you find a long Rumble we ran
hair white calculations that identify
what could be driving what in the system
so we're looking for variations
relationships between genotypes to a
molecular measure that would like to the
record to be a blood-based biomarker
protein marker RNA micro RNA etc to
learn the models because the thurs a
large field gives up many variables it
was six days and had spent time on a pc
saucer so in running these models we
applied certain constraints so even
though we're looking for and trying to
learn the probabilistic relationships
directly from the data set we do apply
some biological difference so DNA
variants can drive variation in any one
of these molecular outputs as well as
clinical parameters it could be
something like age or gender and then
within the molecular variables they can
drive each other and then ultimately
they drive and influence around the
cardiac flash feels like other entrance
represented in this model
then once we learned the models we're
now going to prove it and ask what could
be driving up and really what we're
going to do is run a simulation a
what-if theory that conditions these
models are in a specific patient
background and goes through and
upregulation down really gets every note
of the model mass how does that
variation in the end point and do I see
a strong change in the implant and I
module 8 anyone of these state applies
here anywhere these foods on site i'd
mentioned we've just completed these
results you do plan to publish on these
but so far we're really finding a lot of
interesting biology in the models a
whole set of novel targets associated
with coronary artery disease have
emerged micro RNA target protein targets
and we've also found and discovered
within that the sub networks that
already underlie established biology
some molecular genomic networks around
LDL allergies so today with this
approach of really thinking uptrend
about how we want to design our site not
be it an observational study or clinical
study where we want to go through an
exercise of measuring all of what we
think are the relevant components to be
able to recapitulate and Lauren B
disease models as well as setting up an
experimental design that supports
training and validation we built today
what is one of the largest moth
molecular engine or models under life
are your arteries we've identified no
mechanisms within the small as well as
novel mechanisms and even mechanisms
around known targets but where we want
to be able to learn and establish more
of the end of analysis and now we aim to
apply this framework and make at home
generate other predictions around
justification predictions striae
treatment pathway for their biological
discovery I will continue I'm going to
go through another fakes patient in the
time that happened this is work that has
been published as a post
patient at the ash meeting December in a
different collaboration with an all
smiling of existence and our goal here
was to build fossil disease models
underlying most myeloma and then to make
those models accessible to a group of
researchers that are associated with
myeloma and the condensate so the idea
here is we're going to create and design
a registry that allows us to learn from
these data set problem networks
underlying ultima loma our focus here
was on movie diagnose agents so
everybody in the study is a newly
diagnosed patients remember being
followed by keenly where molecular
levels are being measured along tips and
a whole host of simple data against the
tumors that was left and the patients
are in different treatment around image
revlimid etc so you took in that data
and build models underlying the system
and then interrogated them and what
we've shut up here is a process of
learning and confirmation for every six
months or so the registry data is
enriched with milk patients we take in
that additional data and upload it into
the grass platform to update the model
and we end up learning you links and
associations because you have more data
and while insight and we do make these
models available to members of the
consortium so that's permission can go
in and access it and ask their own what
if questions come up with their own
three and generate their own hypothesis
not sure what that looks like so in this
case to Reese abstract you save a
network this is either the results from
the source data refresh we have
continued the Freddy and we're working
on other data researchers we have about
800 patients again starting from that
law data plan C measures long
normalization etc to come up with about
28,000 a few minutes variables that
showed variation in that study and
that's what the mom and it goes wrong
and their variables complete to the barn
is he snips special variant popping in
the variation as well
clinical data helps with things like a
first responder able progression-free
survival overall and now structurally we
can allow for interactions between the
genetic variables we RNA seek variables
and in some cases here the RNA speech or
molecular levels can modulate the
clinical phenotypes images look for what
toggle for down vertical axis there's
some results from the models obsessed us
honing in on specific sub networks to
see what kinds of relationships
customers and so one of the wrong
drivers of response in the system was
stem cell transplants and that's
reassuring so we're learning that
relationship directly from the data
itself but and but this is a variable
and a mechanism that's known to be
important for subjecting overall
survival and most of my loyalties and so
sort of what you end up learning to make
models are known associations as well as
you want as well as solidifying our
knowledge behind what with you know and
so while it's you know that stem cells
it's south interstate can have an impact
mobile 50 we're learning more and well
how impactful in that easy overall are
the first one speeding for therapy and
so we clear indeed models to identify
other factors that could be driving the
influence so while we went through and
conditioned the model on specific
phenotypes to specification to that what
happens if I up-regulates or down
regulate all the nodes in the model and
and we find then a whole set of targets
essential genes that drive gentle and
those classified into different models
some of them are known since things that
have been reported in the literature
that now is strongly supported by the
models from the data they also classify
and so partially numb things what i like
to call them known under so some of
these might be targets and mechanisms
that i've been afforded in other cancer
types but we're filtering up as a point
here and then some are completely new
and novel molecular driver Jeter
here's an example of another mechanism
that was pulled out of the model it was
around the PDK 9 halfway and it's driver
RNA RNA 7 f ck so r n8 of an education
got to be an important driver for fur
students to last that last that lead to
one year before a progressive disease
and while TV canine and this mechanism
of something that was known about the
new association that was the levels of
unique to first treatment of thought
within that one year conference and some
of these insights essentially could help
redesign how we look at files but are
making up that mess maybe we need to
look at shorter duration treatment
responses where I was on long over there
already clinical trials underway for
that target and mechanism and we're
hoping that some of these insights can
help like how much travel design or
education to be end up using info back
from I see the third some questions that
have come up and I'm going to learn
shortly in my presentations well I will
address them into one of our goals in
his version hearing these models was to
create tools that were not just
accessible to statisticians that left we
reduce models in an hour or sat
environment and the models are available
to folks in our staff and can go in we
have sweater questions and run your own
scripts your own simulation series but
we wanted them to be accessible to a
biologist or submission and so we
created a visualization sweet interface
that allows someone who doesn't really
want to strip down your house is only
names are busy and this is the interface
simulation huy for the most my little
bottles you can go in and her legend can
come up and I can show you now all the
different variables that I represented
in the model somewhere and they see the
clinical variables of various neurotic
in German variables like somatic
mutations of copy number variation you
can then hone in on specific parts of
this model from this case somebody
screwing over Jack one there knows
upstream of that node predicted
do that all right and you can pick two
things and ask you what happens if I set
there's no specific letter at level how
does that vary or modulate the output in
this case the user shows me two targets
and then then you hit the simulate
button and what the model we simulate is
the impact of modulating this snow here
on that final output node this is a
predictive simulation and there's a
predicted to be an association album
link between these two based on of
simulations that you can also go back
and look at the raw data so it gives
biology systems an intuitive you as to
what is going on in the network model
that hopefully they can use and leverage
further in their research and then a
couple more of ways that we are using
these models so as i described taking
the data and the reverse engineering
network models underlying the data but
there's more than one networks
represented in these models and the
population of models will preserve two
things it has made it can be due to
certain things are sometimes I had to
say it especially when you notice
certain saucers upset networks emerging
can also be due to the emergence of
subgroups and some populations within
the data set within study and so I got a
phone on what we're doing with these
most my level models if we're analyzing
them to identify these subgroups as well
as potential biomarkers that could
classify who are any patients that are
more likely to respond to treatment like
Revlimid of combinations of Zoe
listeners and then finally the other use
case is really around once these models
are validated in various settings
whether its retrospective and that
eventually perspective and the final
validation stage is like a strategy free
can we then use these insights and these
mechanisms really impact a success as i
said the bottom shelf and compasses of
causal mechanisms you can run
simulations it comes with very specific
targeted correlation
in the example of the cardiovascular
coronary studies now one can select new
data on patients their clinical lab
values in the genomics that can be cited
into a integrated clinical IT program
what's a new data that's on those
mutations can be fed back into the model
and where we can start to use these
models to come up with insights that are
specific to that patient around their
disease progression with them
potentially optimal desk reading and
leverage some of these findings are as
well around further targeting around
simple imaging lab testing genomics that
we made that a dancer gets little
insight so with that I think I'm Adam my
main time for presenting but you have
time for questions on browser address
them now and I see there's a couple up
there already the first question thank
you dr. khalil for that informative
presentation we do have some questions
I'm going to let our audience know how
to submit them if you have a question
you'd like to ask dr. khalil right now
you can type it into the green QA box
push on the green Q&A button in the
lower left put your question in and hit
send our first question is have you
applied your analysis to systems that
appeared promising enough to launch
discovery programs but ultimately failed
clinically does your analysis show that
the target actually had poor causative
power
related to my last session how do you
assign a confidence when they're to the
primary data use in developing the model
so i assume here are you talking about
the confidence to the actual models of
film or confidence around the data so
confident around the data itself to
develop error models that that can help
a sign of confidence measure to the data
and that gets propagated all the way
through in those days in sports and
around that the final offer and then the
confidence in what we predict is
propagated both on the floor level and
try to capture as much of annoyed or a
certainty as you can that might for
example be really different resonant
moment but also propagated to the
ensemble where we use the hedge anemia
trembles and trust what where is it a
projected stern we have another question
although computational models can be
used to predict disease susceptibility
and rest to what extent an in vivo
models especially those that can be
rapidly generated using castanon
technology accelerate the development
and implementation of targeted
therapeutics or precision person that's
a very good question so ultimately in
this frame of reverse engineering and
then in silico catching up target within
the framework of the computer model you
have access to Padrino and never target
in the mall and in siliguri can screen
many different potential hypotheses and
then the goal is to come up with the
mechanisms are the targets that you're
most confident in that you don't want to
go quickly validated so I teach these
technologies and I'm Christopher a large
scale as iron or steel is further in a
blender where I would like to see all of
this gel is where we keep setup paradigm
of model learning and in silico
validations that are very quick and
actually quicken the feedback loop we
find what we're able to predict and
smooth out and while were able to
validate and in those quick feedback
loops will generate more data every time
we validate something what we learn to
be correct or incorrect or in confidence
in a prediction unless though and that
data can be fed back in these models can
become more and more accurate intense
help us recapitulate more accurately
mechanisms underlying recipes so I can
be students working in school all right
I did not hear the answer to my first
question ah ok so i will go fast enough
alright so in terms of our systems that
appeared promising enough to do a launch
discovery program but ultimately failed
clinically so when we've done these
analyses we have found things that
retrospectively the model says would not
have been a great target and later or at
some
point have shown not for clinically but
we haven't got as far as I find the
target of this further out in clinical
development see that but we do see their
stories bubble up and hop out of the
models things that oh how do you apply
this platform and this technology
combined with United enormous we put up
more quickly either validated something
almost to sell something you can see
those stories emerged from it but it was
early stages and what they're finally
getting these things launch until Isis
take not only will be see more of these
mechanisms that either looks more
promising or like challenging that then
provide our clinical product or not but
we'll be a little further in the closet
okay thank you dr. coolio we've had some
great questions that's great
presentation I want to ask you if since
we don't see any more questions in our
queue do you have any final comments for
our attendees any other information you
could pass on are you to reach out to me
directly if you have other questions or
would like to have any of this content
15 also many of the studies subscribe
today we have published on so we can
send you those sisters and publications
as well
great thank you very much I want to
thank dr. Cleo for all at current time
today presenting this information to us
I also want to thank lab routes comm for
making this web seminar possible before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through the end of
August 2016 attendees will receive an
email from lab roots alerting them when
the mesh when this webcast is available
for replay and we invite you to forward
that email to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
goodbye